der welt zufolge scheidig ein einsamer
weg zu den weg anfangen mir ganz viel
kollege ganz viel glück und am schluss
man bewegte vita und twitter macht dann
verabschiedet sich verliebt
da es nicht der ist wirklich andere
interessant interesse hat oder einfach
normale angestellte wenn sie was ich
jetzt muss ich halt machen und erst
möglich am schluss steht nur mit der
familie nach aber der bruch in ihrem
laden welt familie ist wichtigster finde
ich selbst bemalte sie da oben
[Musik]
ainsley bereich werden
dem ordnet er nicht alles aber vieles
unter ihr eilt von termin zu termin von
geschäft zu geschäft von erfolg zu
erfolg
neuerdings kauf der grundstücke und
treibt die planung eines projektes bis
zur baugenehmigung voran dann verkauft
er alles an einen generalunternehmer
selbstverständlich mit gutem gewinn und
gesetzt
das ist wir befinden uns in der
ostschweiz an der grenze zu
liechtenstein
hier sollen vier terrassen häuser
entstehen geplanter verkaufspreis knapp
900000 franken pro wohneinheit aufsicht
inklusive der steigere das haus neu
renoviert form noch da und man ist so
kenne klärte und mit einem freundlich
respekt nur ein tropfen und eigentlich
ist konzentrieren
heute ist der star sein architekt denn
mit geld bewegt man nicht nur dinge
sondern auch menschen
das gilt freilich auch für nachbarn die
einsprachen erheben oder es auch lassen
können
dennoch wurde die ganze welt letztlich
natürlich nicht beteiligt aber wenn
jetzt einfach gemacht die idee ist vom
einsteiger eigentlich nur besser eine
person kann man auch die positionen
hinter dem bald ist es immer noch besser
und jetzt jetzt eigentlich noch voll
profitiert auf der straße oder
kanalisation und christi und das nicht
darin botschaft also mehr verletzen wenn
es formiere sich aus betrachten wobei
geben ja seliger denn nehmen sein soll
kommt hinzu dass das letzte hemd sowieso
keine taschen hat wer wüsste das besser
als in wesley
[Musik]
vor fünf jahren traf ich ihn zum ersten
mal ist selbstständig seit er 19 sagte
er
damals starb seine großmutter und die
familie suchte vergeblich nach einem
muslimischen bestatter vermutlich hätten
andere das gleiche problem dachte er
sich und sagte seinem vater er würde
eine firma gründen und dienststellen
zwei uncool und ein cousin des
verstorbenen sind gekommen die eltern
und die geschwister sind bereits nach
kosovo ausgeflogen
die zeit drängt vom tod bis zur
beisetzung sollten im islam nicht mehr
als 48 stunden vergehen
[Musik]
der tote wird gründlich gewaschen werde
ewigkeit im paradies verbringen will der
sollte ryan vor allah dritten erklärt
mich vor
man fand ich so schweizer die krise
strikt sind nämlich schon belastend
gesehen in der nacht erfolgt nachts im
schlaf und so dass die schlacht träumt
und ja zum beispiel das ist der feine
zeichnung
man muss das klarträumen berufliches und
privates und dass man das macht so
besser kannten gab es nimmt ein kirche
das mal mit wenn man dachte immer
eigentlich trafen und etwas für die
familie und dann haben sie ansprechen
sagt große familie
das hat mich beschäftigt ich weiß nicht
wann ich zum edgar davids zum beispiel
ihrer foster war schon mal mit stern ja
meine das mit vor der seite machen
das ist für mich selbstverständlich dass
ich das mache eigentlich
[Musik]
ein regisseur der fall aufmerksam und
engagierte in spontan für einen kurzfilm
namens facing mekka er spielt einen
muslimischen bestatter also sich selbst
die geschichte dreht sich um einen
syrischen flüchtlingen dessen frau
stirbt weil die gemeinde kein
muslimisches grabfeld zur verfügung
stellen will findet sie ihre letzte ruhe
mit fast hilfe in einem wald hier wird
kein geld allenfalls ruhm der weg
dorthin ist jedoch steinig
ich glaub nicht dass ich glaube nicht
durchs netz ich würde mich als der stadt
verabschiedet das für ihn nicht
das ist gerade baut sich schließlich die
scherben und doch es ist wirklich altes
neues berufsfeld als wir zu wenige
märkte im fehlen gesetze immer guten
schluss so aber jetzt die letzten tagen
betreut und es ist so viel arbeit
dadurch wirkt das spürt dass jedes land
empfehlen wert was hätte es für den
titel jetzt so kurz ich brauch' ich sage
also will ich immer gern alles machen
ich glaube ehrlich herr machen oder so
also nicht weil ich so gern machen und
ausprobieren
ja er macht wird jetzt kann man jetzt
ganz spontan
wieso nur diese permanente
betriebsamkeit
mit dieser frage reisten wir vor fünf
jahren ins presseportal eine albanische
enklave auf serbischem gebiet nahe der
kosovarischen grenze die heimat seiner
eltern
[Musik]
hier verbrachte seine ersten sechs
lebensjahre
dann holte sein vater der saison in die
schweiz gegangen war ihn und seine zwei
brüder nach das leben sollte ihnen eine
chance geben
darauf hatten seine onkel und cousins
immer noch in den wintermonaten liegt
die arbeitslosigkeit hier nahe bei 100
prozent die zeit steht still bis in den
nächsten sommerferien die verwandten aus
dem ausland auf besuch kommen
doch nicht alle die nicht mit armut
perspektivlosigkeit
ja
[Musik]
hassli macht eine lehre als
sachbearbeiter und baute nebenbei ein
bestattungsunternehmen auf er arbeitet
und arbeitet als ob in die armut dicht
auf den fersen blieben
[Musik]
wäre sie wahrscheinlich millionär
wertnote millionen etat aber dass ich
mir keine sorgen machen es kalt und dass
ich mal irgendein anderes land hat kohl
aber wohl nicht so viel stress
ausgesetzt ist so vielseitig und einfach
zurück so wird sie nicht langweilig
langweilig und sie würde einen richtigen
zurück das wäre dann immer die schweizer
ja das ist jugendlich nach vergeblichen
so enttäuscht jugend noch nicht so
kaputt wie die schweiz also ausgang
könne sich sein bescheidenes und
jugend-cup die schweiz aus ihrer sicht
aus meiner sicht wird das wochenende
könnte ausgang alkohol drogen lassen
stellte das rasante respekt vor den
älteren vor dem auftritt in sicherlich
mittag ins labor idealisiert
das könnte sich das könnte sie wenn sie
dann zurück wie krimis ideen auf gewalt
ist opel kritisch das ist wahrscheinlich
also aber ich sage das ist eine
möglichkeit ich einen aktionstag des
heimatlands das haus in dem er seine
ersten jahre verbrachte steht seit
langem leer
inzwischen wohnt mit seinen eltern und
brüdern in einem mehrfamilienhaus im
kanton solothurn alles finanziert von
wesley
ein klassisches konzert an bord also
[Musik]
schulstoff things come dann einfach an
kopf
da bin ich oft verdammt sind
herr baum nicht cosmetics zeit hier ging
es für ihn stetig aufwärts alles eine
frage des willens sagte er
sind sie denn ihre youtube sie früher
doch ganz am anfang schon ich liebe aber
ich hatte nicht die tiere ganz anders
auf einmal mehr erfolg dass man hat
desto liebe sie sie mit einem zahmen
oder desto leerer aber hatte sie mit
einem see oder regel mit ihm und er wird
ganz anders behandelt also nicht als
integrierte heilig über erfolg das ist
also das rheintal ist es ist auch in der
schweiz integriert
nun
mußmann risikofreudig oder einfach
riskieren will
ohne das ministrieren hätten auch nicht
davor und mit us- offen mit ihrer
familie vernachlässigen und und judas
zum erfolg
und wer erfolgreich ist der kann immer
noch erfolgreicher werden
neben seinen immobiliengeschäften ist
der weit raus bestatter unterwegs in
diesem fall richtung zagreb er hat seine
alten muster ihrer karte wir gerade in
kroatien weißt du schon weiß stuhl vor
wo sie sind oder was ende der schweiz
doch sage okay gut
ja ich würde da also danke die toten
schlafen zwar der tod hingegen nicht
gestorben wird immer eine krisensichere
branche also aber auch ein hart
umkämpfter markt hat sich das eilig vor
antritt was sie bereit sind für ihre
toten musste ich bis sie zwölf jahre
geschafft auch so noch als statisten
studiert und ich muss sagen der letzte
jahr hat sich spürbar verändert gelöst
sind einfach weniger bereit für ihre
jetzt haben mit der menschen falle
ältere geldausgabe label made autos für
dich und für die alters- oder was auch
immer
aber jetzt vor der von den älteren denn
wenn sie auch so grundstück und
ermöglicht so schnell und einfach der
direktor der sargfabrik und seine rechte
hand zeigen ihre produktion hier
entstehen jedes jahr 65.000 särge in
allen möglichen variationen möchte seine
produktepalette mit importen aus
kroatien erweitern
er will schon bald eine art brief um die
bestattung anbieten
noch vor italien sind und lust ihnen
bereit das seil oder kreuz nimmt zahlen
und wagt dann italien oder erst
möglichkeit frage was ist bloß los
einige büros lande befähigen und es wird
nur ganz modisch vorhand macht
bedeutet es macht richtig wenn es
sterben hier und jetzt dass wir auch
umso größer sondern auch musik und dort
ist es technisch interessante methode
[Musik]
foxley muss weiter weiter zum nächsten
erfolg
der film facing mekka feiert im zürcher
kino riffraff premiere hat seine kv
lehrmeisterin samt anhang eingeladen und
seine frau er hat sich zeit genommen für
eine hochzeit mit adelina auf seinem
heimatdorf und alles ist gut
[Musik]
sechs stunden der fall
ja
[Musik]
der film kommt nicht nur bei der
premiere gut an sondern gewinnt später
einen preis nach dem anderen und
internationalen festivals und verpasst
in moskau nur um haaresbreite eine neue
erfahrung für vossloh lohn in form von
applaus der insel habe ich sehr gut
in deutschland im board kws kosten
gemacht
die kosten der verbraucher zu wahren
begebenheit
wo mehr dass er engagiert und der in
wahrheit und das haben wir stehen auch
in einem see gefunden der achte fall
begleitet und das ist bei die eine
glücksformel
beim apéro erzählt er er habe die tote
damals ausfliegen lassen wie aber mascus
in heimischer erde auch dass ein voller
erfolg
einer bei dem er gerne drauf gelegt habe
gehen wir auf
[Applaus]
heute verkauft er mehrere
immobilienprojekte an ein investoren
gruppe es geht um viel geld um sehr viel
geld
[Applaus]
diese unterschrift macht aus dem machen
einen gemachten man gerade zur
lehrerschaft aus gute vielleicht fürs
vertrauen darauf hingearbeitet endlich
das große geld mit 32 millionen
man weiß man jetzt abgeschlossen
er ist froh dass es erfolgreich
abgeschlossen worden ist
aber er herzt eigentlich besser erwartet
im inneren vorstellen wenn ich das wenn
ich das schaffe denn denn wichtig so
eine freude ist warum macht das ding
aber eigentlich ist nicht so
die binsenweisheit stimmt also geld
allein macht nicht glücklich aber es
macht offenbar appetit appetit auf mehr
wieso nur ein porsche wenn man auch noch
einen zweiten haben könnte
[Musik]